un teint blafard 2 trop pointu et un
corps glacés à première vue côté
séduction un vampire
c'était pas évident évident et puis il
ya la vie quotidienne ils ne peuvent
dormir que dans la terre de leurs
cercueils et règne l'ail et rémy
crucifix la lumière du jour
notre vampire a un côté très chaude
quand même et pourtant cette fragilité
leur en craquant en 1969 christopher lee
l'inoubliable dracula du cinéma semblait
avoir apprécié son rôle leur brosse les
femmes les femmes sur les esclaves
si les fans sont tellement accro c'est
que lorsqu'un vampire immortel vous mord
dans le coup il vous rend jeune et belle
pour l'éternité
et cerise sur le gâteau c'est un grand
romantique
en tout cas c'est ce qu'affirme et cette
étudiante en vampire au logis en 1997 le
vampire nous peut prendre sa victime
simplement pour une nourriture où il
peut être complètement partagé entre son
sentiment de deux prédateurs et son
sentiment amoureux il peut totalement
tombé amoureux de la victime
autre avantage à fréquenter un vampire
son standing
dracula compte de son état sera ravi de
vous accueillir dans son château de bran
en roumanie et qui sait il y a peut être
une chambre d'enfant dans ce château
cependant sachez le votre bambin
pourrait ne pas être aussi innocent que
ça grg déjà mort de la manne mon père y
avait un gros comme ça je vais si elle
seule 100 mais si ce tableau de famille
ne vous fait pas rêver
pas d'inquiétude pour rompre avec un
vampire le plus simple pour lui briser
le coeur
ce sera d'y planter un pieux en bois et
vous pourrez profiter de votre longue
vie dix mortels
[Musique]